We all passed through miserable moments where we felt ready to eat anything.
But, what if your only choice: human flesh?
Most of us have heard of eating the instance, but what will happen if people eat?
In principle, if we look at insects, snails, fish and amphibians, we will see that they eat each other a lot.
For example, the mother's cancerous spider puts non-fertilized eggs for its young to eat,
Once they have finished eating the eggs, they offer themselves a night in a process called Matriphagy,
But for mammals, eat a rare instance.
It is usually due to environmental stresses, such as with rabbits when young children eat at difficult situations.
French paleontologists found human bones of a primitive human being a hundred thousand years old.
Bone fractures appeared to extract the brain and eat the brain.
And traces of cutting with a tool indicating that the tongue and thigh were also eaten.
Even in the 20th century, the use of the analogy was used for medical reasons when human blood was prescribed treatment for some.
This brings us back to the first question,
You are at risk for any blood-transmitted disease such as hepatitis or Ebola that the victim may be carrying.
As well as the risk of infection of E. coli bacteria and gastrointestinal bacteria at the victim.
Speaking of blood, we certainly have red meat. This is due to myoglobin (a protein linked to iron and oxygen, found in the muscle tissue).
What is your nutritional value?
Hassan, your thigh is worth about ten thousand calories, and your heart seven hundred calories, and your body full eighty-one thousand calories.
But about half of those calories come from fat or fatty tissue, which means you are not the most appropriate option for dieters.
Although the pastries say that our taste is between pork and calf, and nice cooking robots we classified as bacon,
There is still a greater risk in the so-called primitives.
Though not fully understood, prions are copies of a normal protein that has been altered so that it loses its function and becomes contagious.
Distorted proteins can distort similar healthy proteins, causing a chain reaction and disease.
Precisely, the disease causes brain disease in the brain, giving it a spongy appearance and, ultimately, death.
However, unlike viruses, bacteria, fungus or parasitic infections that contain DNA or ribosomal DNA,
Braids do not contain nucleic acids, which means they do not kill by radiation or heat
These infectious glands may exist in any of the nerve tissues including organs and muscles.
But they are more common in the brain and spinal nerve tissue.
That is, the risk of infection is high if you consume meat containing the primates.
All the brain, and the risk will rise dramatically!
In the 1950s, researchers discovered that a number of members of the Furai tribe (tribe in Papua, New Guinea)
Suffering from a disease called Kuro or Laughter Disease.
The disease loses the human control of his feelings and then the functions of his body, and eventually subject him to death.
It turns out that Kuro was (Bryon's disease) caused by their funerary rituals.
The Faurai believe that it is better to eat the dead they love rather than to eat worms and insects.
The weather is believed to have died down, but the incubation of the Prairian disease could last for 50 years.
That is, other cases of the disease may appear.
Therefore, although cannibalism is not necessarily harmful to you, especially if the meat is free of prairies,
But the risk of infection is high, and nothing worth the risk!
Be a beef steak, unless you are a human being, there are a lot of creatures that eat like them, keep going!
See our section on the strangest ten creatures you eat in nature, here.
And participated in the channel for more scientific sections every Thursday. Translation: team translate @autrjim